>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
VARIOUS NEWS OUTLETS ARE TELLING
US THAT THE MUELLER REPORT IS
FINALLY ON ITS WAY.
WE HAVE NO INSIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT.
WE SHOULD SAY APPARENTLY THE
WHITE HOUSE BELIEVES IT, TOO.
MUELLER'S REPORT DOES ARRIVE, IT
WILL GO FIRST TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
THERE'S NOT MUCH DEBATE ABOUT
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN AFTER THAT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE DEMANDED THE
RELEASE OF THE ENTIRE DOCUMENT.
THE PRESIDENT AGREES WITH THEM.
HE SAID HE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
REPORT GO PUBLIC SO VOTERS CAN
ASSESS IT FOR THEMSELVES.
FOR NOW, WE'D LIKE TO TAKE JUST
A SECOND TO PUT THIS ENTIRE
SPRAWLING STORY INTO SOME
PERSPECTIVE.
OUR JOB ON THIS SHOW IS TO
REMEMBER THINGS, TO CREATE A
RECORD OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
THIS COUNTRY OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
IT.
OUR GRANDCHILDREN WILL WANT TO
KNOW.
IF THE LEFT HAS ITS WAY, IT WILL
ALL BE WHITEWASHED LIKE SO MUCH
ELSE IN OUR HISTORY HAS BEEN.
LET'S RECALL FOR THE RECORD WHAT
THE ROBERT MUELLER INVESTIGATION
IS ALL ABOUT.
THE POINT WAS NOT TO DISCOVER BE
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT FUDGED
DEDUCTIONS ON HIS TAX RETURNS 30
YEARS AGO, NOT TO FIND OUT
WHETHER HE WANTED TO BUILD A
HOTEL IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION WAS
JUSTIFIED BY A SINGLE QUESTION:
DID DONALD TRUMP COLLUDE WITH
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TO STEAL
THE 2016 ELECTION?
DID THE PRESIDENT BETRAY HIS
COUNTRY?
FOR THREE YEARS, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE TOLD US, YES, HE DID DO
THAT.
>> IT'S BEYOND A SHADOW OF DOUBT
TO ME, THERE WAS AT LEAST THE
EFFORT TO COLLUDE.
>> THERE'S MORE TO BE LEARNED
ABOUT IT.
I BELIEVE THERE'S BEEN
COLLUSION.
>> IT'S STARTING TO SMELL MORE
AND MORE LIKE COLLUSION.
>> WE SAW COLD, HARD EVIDENCE OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THE TRUMP
FAMILY EAGERLY INTENDING TO
COLLUDE POSSIBLY WITH RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE NOT MINOR
CHARGES.
IF YOU GREW UP IN THIS COUNTRY,
IT IS HARD TO SHRUG THEM OFF.
MAXINE WATERS IS IRRELEVANT.
SHE'S A LIVING SIDE SHOW.
NANCY PELOSI IS THIRD IN LINE TO
THE PRESIDENCY.
ADAM SCHIFF IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
JOHN PODESTA WAS THE CHIEF OF
STAFF IN ONE WHITE HOUSE.
HE WAS A SENIOR ADVISOR IN
ANOTHER WHITE HOUSE.
BETO O'ROURKE HAS RAISED MORE
MONEY THAN ANYONE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2020.
THEY'RE THE MOST SERIOUS PEOPLE
IN THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
AND WE TOOK THEM SERIOUSLY.
WE FELT WE HAD A DUTY TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WERE CALLING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES A TRAITOR.
WE INTERVIEWED A NUMBER OF THOSE
PEOPLE ON THIS SHOW.
ONE OF THE MOST PERSISTENT
ACCUSERS WAS FROM CALIFORNIA,
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
IF WAS THEREIN DEED EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA, HE WOULD
HAVE SEEN IT.
HE NEVER PRODUCED ANY, AND WE
ASKED HIM REPEATEDLY.
HE ACCUSED US OF CUTTING HIM OFF
ON THE AIR.
FINALLY, WE OFFERED HIM A FULL
HALF HOUR LIVE ON THIS SHOW TO
TELL US WHAT THE EVIDENCE WAS.
>> IF YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE AT
ALL OF COLLUSION, ANY -- AND I
DON'T CARE HOW SMALL IT IS, I
WILL GIVE THE FLOOR TO YOU.
I MEAN THAT.
I WANT TO WRAP THIS UP.
I'M SURE YOU DO, TOO.
>> Tucker: MONTHS LATER, HE CAME
ON THE SHOW, BUT HE NEVER
PRODUCED A SINGLE PIECE OF
EVIDENCE THAT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COLLUDED WITH ANYONE.
INSTEAD, HE ACCUSED US OF
WORKING FOR A FOREIGN POWER.
WE ASKED WHY THE PUBLIC COULDN'T
SEE A MEMO RELATED TO THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
HERE'S HOW HE RESPONDED.
>> IN THE CASE OF TODAY'S MEMO,
WHAT SPECIFICALLY HAVE I
ESPOUSED THAT EMPOWERS THREATS
TO OUR COUNTRY?
>> YOU'RE PEDDLING THE NARRATIVE
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
PUTTING OUT, WHICH ALSO IS THE
PUTIN NARRATIVE BECAUSE THEY'RE
RETWEETING THIS WITH THEIR
RUSSIAN BOTS.
>> DO YOU PERCEIVE --
>> -- WIKILEAKS AND PUTIN, YOU
SHOULD TAKE A STEP BACK AND
WONDER WHOSE BIDDING ARE YOU
REALLY DOING.
>> Tucker: SO FOR ASKING TO SEE
A GOVERNMENT DOCUMENT HE HIMSELF
HAD SEEN, HE SUGGESTED WE WERE
TREASONOUS.
THERE'S BEEN AN AWFUL LOT OF
TALK LIKE THAT THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS.
PEOPLE IN THIS CITY ARE AFRAID.
THEY WATCH WHAT THEY SAY, THEY
DON'T SEND E-MAILS.
THE BEGINNING OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, THERE'S BEEN
VIRTUALLY NO HONEST, PUBLIC
DEBATE ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING
OR HAS HAPPENED.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE FROM THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF CAME ON THE
SHOW.
WE ASKED A FACT-BASED QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT WE KNOW AND DON'T
KNOW.
IT WAS: ARE WE CERTAIN THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT HACKED JOHN
PODESTA'S G-MAIL ACCOUNT?
>> CAN YOU SAY I KNOW FOR A FACT
THE GOVERNMENT OF --
>> ABSOLUTELY, THE GOVERNMENT OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS BEHIND THE
HACKS OF --
>> OF JOHN PODESTA'S E-MAIL.
OF JOHN --
>> ALSO IN EUROPE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT -- LOOK AND SAY
I KNOW THEY DID --
>> AND I THINK THAT RONALD
REAGAN WOULD BE --
>> RONALD REAGAN.
>> AS YOU'RE CARRYING WATER FOR
THE KREMLIN.
>> YOU'RE A SITTING MEMBER OF
CONGRESS AND YOU CAN'T SAY --
>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE
YOUR SHOW TO RUSSIAN TELEVISION.
>> Tucker: SO TO THIS DAY, EVEN
THE MOST BASIC, THE MOST
ELEMENTAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CLAIMS IN THIS RUSSIA STORY
REMAIN UNANSWERED.
WE'VE UPENDED OUR ENTIRE FOREIGN
POLICY AND PUT AMERICANS IN
PRISON ALL ON THE BASIS OF
CHARGES THAT NO ONE HAS BEEN
WILLING TO PROVE.
THE CONSPIRACY HAWKS SEEM
TOTALLY IMPERVIOUS TO SHAME OR
REASON.
THEY WOULDN'T ENGAGE.
THEY JUST THREW SLURS.
THEY FELT NO NEED TO DEMONSTRATE
ANY OF IT WAS TRUE.
>> AT WHAT POINT DO YOU DRAW THE
LINE AND NOT ACCUSE THE
PRESIDENT WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE?
>> HE'S BETRAYED OR COUNTRY.
I DON'T SAY THAT LIGHTLY.
>> BETRAYING THE COUNTRY, BY THE
WAY, WE WANT EVIDENCE BEFORE YOU
SAY THAT, BUT YOU SAID AN AGENT
OF RUSSIA.
>> HE WORKS ON THEIR BEHALF.
>> AS A PROSECUTOR, YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HARD EVIDENCE
AND CIRCUMSTANTIAL ED
AND CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE.
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR.
IT'S ALMOST HIDING IN PLAIN
SIGHT.
>> Tucker: SOME OF THE MOST
RESPECTED, SUPPOSEDLY SOBER
FIGURES IN OUR SOCIETY ENGAGED
IN THIS BEHAVIOR FOR YEARS.
THEY SAID THINGS THAT WERE SO
RECKLESS AND DAMAGING TO THIS
COUNTRY IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE IT
WAS HAPPENING.
NOT SO LONG AGO, JOHN BRENNAN
WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE CIA, THE
MOST POWERFUL INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY IN THE WORLD.
>> REPORTING RIGHT NOW THAT
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
HAS EVIDENCE THAT MICHAEL COHEN
SECRETLY MADE A LATE SUMMER TRIP
TO PRAGUE DURING THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
ACCORDING TO NEWS SOURCES
FAMILIAR WITH THE MATTER.
CONFIRMATION OF THE TRIP WOULD
AFFIRM PART OF THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
>> REPORTS THAT MR. COHEN WAS IN
PRAGUE DESPITE HIS DENIALS.
THERE IS MORE AND MORE OCCASIONS
THAT THERE IS -- INDICATIONS
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING HERE
THAT IS FAR, FAR FROM BEING
ANYTHING NEAR A WITCH HUNT.
>> Tucker: MICHAEL COHEN WAS IN
PRAGUE MEETING WITH HIS RUSSIAN
HANDLERS.
THAT'S WHAT BRENNAN JUST TOLD US
ON CABLE TELEVISION.
YOU'D THINK IF ANYONE WOULD KNOW
THAT FACT, IT WOULD BE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CIA.
THE CIA KNOWS ALL.
EXCEPT PERHAPS ON THIS ONE
QUESTION, MICHAEL COHEN HIMSELF
MIGHT KNOW MORE.
HE WAS ASKED DIRECTLY ABOUT IT.
COHEN HAD NO REASON TO PROTECT
DONALD TRUMP.
HE HAD MANY REASONS TO HURT HIM.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN TO PRAGUE.
>> NEVER HAVE.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN TO THE CZECH
REPUBLIC.
>> YIELD THE BALANCE OF MY TIME.
>> COHEN ALSO TOLD CONGRESS IN
ALL HIS YEARS WORKING AS DONALD
TRUMP'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY, ONE
OF THE MOST INTD MAT
RELATIONSHIPS IN DONALD TRUMP'S
LIFE, HE'D NEVER SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
CASE CLOSED.
BUT IT WAS TOO LATE.
BY THAT POINT, THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION HAD BECOME SUCH A
BONANZA THAT THEY COULDN'T SLOW
DOWN.
THEY HAD NO INCENTIVE TO ADMIT
DEFEAT OR ACKNOWLEDGE REALITY.
THEY CONTINUED AS THEY HAD AS IF
THE STORY WAS ENTIRELY REAL.
THEY BROUGHT US AN ENDLESS
PARADE OF SCREAMERS, BAFOONS AND
HALF WITS.
MALCOLM NANCE DELIVERING HIS
ANALYSIS ON MSNBC.
>> WHEN BENEDICT ARNOLD GAVE THE
PLANS TO WEST POINT, THEY DID
NOT HAVE ANY REAL INFORMATION
LINKING THOSE PLANS TO BENEDICT
ARNOLD OTHER THAN THE FACT HE
WAS IN HIS PRESENCE AT ONE POINT
DURING THAT DAY.
EVERYONE KNEW IT WAS TREASON
WHEN THEY CAUGHT THE MAN AND
THEY HUNG HIM.
AT SOME POINT, THERE'S GOING TO
BE UNSAILABLE.
>> THANKS FOR THE HISTORY
LESSON, MR. NANCE.
THEY HUNG HIM.
LET'S HANG THIS GUY.
AFTER A WHILE, AFTER YEARS OF
THIS, VOTERS STARTED TO AGREE.
THANKS TO PROPAGANDA LIKE YOU
JUST SAW.
53% OF REGISTERED VOTERS BELIEVE
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WORKED WITH
RUSSIA TO INFLUENCE THE 2016
ELECTION.
AMONG DEMOCRATIC VOTERS, 67%
BELIEVE RUSSIA SOMEHOW RIGGED
THE VOTE TALLY.
NOBODY'S EVER EXPLAINED HOW
EXACTLY THE RUSSIANS MIGHT HAVE
DONE THAT, BUT OF COURSE THEY
DID IT.
RUSSIA RIGGED THE ELECTION.
CNN SAYS SO EVERY NIGHT.
THERE NEED TO BE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THIS.
ONCE THE MUELLER REPORT APPEARS
AND IT BECOMES APPARENT THAT
DONALD TRUMP DID NOT COLLUDE
WITH THE RUSSIANS, MANY PEOPLE
THAT CLAIM ON NO EVIDENCE THAT
HE DID COLLUDE WITH THE RUSSIANS
OUGHT TO BE PUNISHED.
THOROUGHLY SHAMED AND FORCED TO
APOLOGIZE.
IF REPUBLICANS SPENT THREE FULL
YEARS FALSELY CLAIMING THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA COLLUDED WITH
THE GOVERNMENT OF IRAN, WOULD
THEY EVER WORK IN MEDIA OR
POLITICS AGAIN?
LYING AND RECKLESSNESS SHOULD
NEVER BE IGNORED.
THE UNITED STATES INVADED IRAQ
ON THE PREMISE THAT THEY
POSSESSED CHEMICAL AND
BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS.
MANY BELIEVED IT, BUT THE CLAIM
WAS FALSE.
NOBODY WAS PUNISHED.
TO THIS DAY, MAX BOOT TAKES A
PAYCHECK FROM THE "WASHINGTON
POST."
NO CRYSTAL APPEARS ON MSNBC.
JOHN BOLTON IS THIS COUNTRY'S
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
THERE WERE NO CONSEQUENCES TO
THEIR FOOLISHNESS AND
DISHONESTY, NONE.
INSTEAD WE START WARS WITH
ENTIRELY PREDICTABLE RESULTS.
NOBODY LEARNED ANYTHING.
WILL THE SAME CAST OF LIARS MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT SCAM.
CLIMATE CHANGE, THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
IT'S TOO IMPORTANT.
OBEY OR ELSE.